- You can imagine it's not super easy
to just buy a bridge and
build all this stuff.
It's our American dream,
not everybody dreams
of picket fences and houses;
we dreamt of a bridge.
Bungee jumping gets categorized as more
of a a carnival ride, but
for me and my friends,
it's kind of our sanctuary.
It's not fear; it's just happiness.
Pure happiness.
(upbeat music)
My name is Doug Frutos.
There's four of us that
own Vertigo Bungee.
We've been friends a long time;
been jumping for decades.
We met almost 30 years ago,
and we've been bungee jumping ever since.
The memories that we have
together are priceless.
It's amazing that we've
been friends that long.
We have owned the Young's
High Bridge for six years,
and on the East Coast, we are pretty much
the only ones that jump from a bridge.
Bungee jumping from bridges
is the best way to do it;
that's where bungee jumping
came from originally was from bridges;
and most bridges have that
scenic natural environment,
which is a lot nicer than a parking lot.
(upbeat music)
Because we own this bridge,
we've been able to create
the perfect environment
for bungee jumping.
We have the skill and the ability
to make people feel
confident and comfortable.
You know, we love what we do, we wanna see
everybody jump and have a great time.
Yeah we'll get started, and have fun.
We get every single type of
person you can imagine up here.
You get people that
came out here thinking,
"I'd never do this," they came
out to watch their friend,
the next thing you know, they're jumping
off of the bridge three times.
It is a very safe activity
and allows people to push their limits.
When we're out here,
it puts you in a place
that's just focused on the moment;
you're not thinking about the bills;
you're not thinking about relationships;
you're not thinking about anything
but what's happening to you and what
you're seeing right in front of you.
I mean, those seconds,
they're slow seconds,
they seem longer.
Everything slows down, it's a time,
a short time but it is a time
that I can just focus on the moment.
I don't really ever wanna stop so.
- Even when you're 80 years
old, you want to keep going?
- If I can, yeah.
(Doug laughing)
(upbeat music)
I don't see a day that I'm
gonna stop bungee jumping,
and I don't think my partners will either.
We're gonna jump as much as we can
until we can't anymore.
Coming up on 30 years
and going on 40 or 50.